[Musique]
il s'appelait sudan
c'était le dernier mâle de son espèce il
c'était un le 19 mars 2018
[Musique]
malgré lui soudanais devenu le
rhinocéros le plus célèbre au monde
son histoire c'est celle d'une
extinction celle d'un animal
emblématique éradiquée par l'homme
les histoires de sudan c'est un petit
peu la chronique d'une extinction qu'on
aurait dû éviter et que malheureusement
on a vu se dérouler sous nos yeux
inexorablement malgré les efforts
déployés sudan pour nous c'est un petit
peu un ambassadeur de toutes les espèces
menacées dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
le nom sudan vient de son lieu de
naissance le soudan du sud
ce pays abrite une faune sauvage
incroyable et s'est étendue de nature
comptent parmi les plus belles sur terre
c'est ici que sudan voit le jour en 1973
c'est un rhinocéros blanc du nord une
sous-espèce du rhinocéros blanc avec ses
cousins les rhinocéros blancs du sud
il compte parmi les mammifères
terrestres les plus lourds au monde
les mâles adultes peuvent peser jusqu'à
deux tonnes et demie
[Musique]
historiquement l'air de répartition des
rhinocéros blancs du nord est est
immense
m
[Musique]
mais à la naissance de sudan celle ci a
commencé à se réduire
on estime alors qu'il ne reste qu
environ 700 individus encore en vie et
ce nombre ne cesse de diminuer
car soudain et ses congénères sont
constamment traquer et tuer dans un but
simple obtenir leurs cornes la corde
n'est pas fait d'une matière précieuse
la corne est faite de kératine comme nos
ongles
ce n'est pas une matière précieuse comme
peut l'être l'ivoire d'éléphant par
exemple qui est rare dans la nature
néanmoins la corde seront très chères
parce qu'on associe cet objet à la
puissance de l'animal donc la corne a
une valeur symbolique très forte elle
est utilisée dans différents types
d'artisanat en particulier pour faire
des poignards des manches de poignard
qui sont très appréciés dans les pays
arabes en particulier les pays du golfe
et donc au cours du 20e siècle il ya un
braconnage intense qui frappe les
rhinocéros et qui conduit leurs
effectifs a chuté vertigineusement alors
que la pression du braconnage ne cesse
de grandir
un événement va bouleverser la vie du
jeune sudan au cours des années 70 des
équipes venues d'europe ou des états
unis sont envoyés en afrique à la
recherche d'animaux exotiques
leur but remplir les eaux qui se
multiplient en occident en 1975 une de
ses équipes capture six rhinocéros dans
la savane soudanaise parmi eux le petit
sudan âgé de seulement deux ans
transporté sur des milliers de
kilomètres
ces rhinocéros atterrissent en
république tchèque une nouvelle vie
commence alors pour eux celle de la
captivité dans le zoo de toujours
kralové
c'est ici que sudan passera plus de
trente ans de sa vie
[Musique]
au cours de cette période il devient
père de deux femelles
nadir né en 1983
dena jean né en 1989 en 2000 najib
devient elle-même mère d'une petite
rhinocéros fatou qui fait deux soudanais
un grand-père les conditions de vie sont
parfois difficiles dans le zoo la neige
le froid et le bitume les éloigne
drastiquement de leur environnement
naturel
mais les conservationnistes considère
aujourd'hui que cette captivité leur a
sauvé la vie en effet loin de la
république tchèque
la situation s'aggrave d'année en année
pour les rhinocéros blancs du nord
encore en liberté
entre les années 80 et les années 2000
braconnage intensif instabilité
politique et conflits armés vont avoir
raison des dernières populations
sauvages dans la zone de l'afrique
centrale il ya plusieurs types de
conflits et notamment en république
démocratique du congo
les rhinocéros se trouvait de chasse et
florian d'une part la consommation est
aussi pour la vente de leurs cornes qui
finance les actions des groupes armés au
début des années 2000 on assiste à un
tournant dans le braconnage
parce qu'en fait à cette époque là la
demande pour la corne de rhinocéros
explose en particulier dans les pays
d'asie du sud est l'un des pays
consommateurs comme la thaïlande ne vais
pas vous la chine qui deviennent très
très demandeurs de corps de rhinocéros
du fait de la demande les prix
s'envolent littéralement en l'espace de
20 ans entre le milieu des années 90 et
le milieu d année 2010 le prix de la
corne de rhinocéros passe de 4500
dollars le kilo à plus de 65 mille
dollars le kilo donc on a appris de la
corne qui est plus que décuplé en vingt
ans et comme la corne est vendue au g
ont atteint des prix délirants avec le
gramme de la corne de rhinocéros qui est
équivalent grammes de cocaïne
à ce moment là les on prête des vertus
nombreux zoos à la corne de rhinocéros
on prétend que la corne soigne les maux
d'estomac ou les rhumatismes ou le
cancer des propriétés comptes jamais été
vérifiées et puis à ce moment là il ya
aussi des usages nouveaux qui
apparaissent notamment en lien avec
l'accession à un certain niveau de vie
par exemple au vietnam où la jeunesse
dorée vietnamienne utilise la corne de
rhinocéros boyer en poudre dans des
cocktails
un peu comme un signe extérieur de
richesse en bois des cocktails dans les
bars à la corne de rhinocéros
malheureusement ces usages là en asie
ont des conséquences dramatiques à
l'autre bout du monde où la demande
asiatique entraîne une recrudescence
effréné du braconnage en afrique où le
rhinocéros blancs du nord dont fait
parti soudanais en 2008
les rhinocéros blancs du nord sont
considérés comme éteints à l'état
sauvage
cela fait plus de deux ans que les
scientifiques n'ont observé aucun
individu en liberté malgré de vastes
recherches terrestres et aériennes
une décision inédite est alors prise une
décision qui va de nouveau faire
basculer la vie de susan dans l'espoir
de sauver la sous-espèce un consortium
de vétérinaires et de conservation nist
décide de ramener en afrique certains
des rhinocéros vivent encore au zoo de
dvur kralove et pour les placer dans la
réserve naturelle d'ol pejeta au kenya
rement ainsi cette année la sudan safina
gines sa petite-fille fatou et un autre
mâle souny dit l'europe centrale pour
les plaines africaines le climat et
l'environnement doit fournir des
conditions de reproduction optimale à
ses quatre rhinocéros qui compte parmi
les sept derniers représentants de leur
sous-espèce la menace du braconnage
étant toujours présente les nouveaux
arrivants sont surveillés 24 heures sur
24 par des gardes armés
jour et nuit des rangers restent auprès
des rhinocéros à l'affût des braconniers
[Musique]
les vétérinaires de la réserve se charge
de leur apporter tous les soins
nécessaires malheureusement ce qu'on
espérait ne se produit pas dire que à
cette époque soudanais déjà très âgés
donc son sperme n'est sans doute plus
très performant très fertile et puis les
faits tels qu'ils sont avec lui ne sont
apparemment pas apte à la reproduction
et donc tous les accouplements qui ont
lieu ne donne lieu à aucune naissance en
2014 sous ni le deuxième mal venu de
république tchèque décède
la même année c'est au tour dans galy
faut un autre mâle présent au zoo de san
diego sudan devient alors le dernier
représentant mâle des rhinocéros blancs
du nord
il est surnommé de la semaine standing
le dernier homme debout pour les
conservationnistes une course contre la
montre s'engage alors il faut prélever
le sperme de sudan avant son décès puis
parvenir à inséminer artificiellement
une femelle
sinon les rhinocéros blancs du nord
seront perdus
[Musique]
pour financer ce projet une campagne est
lancée sur l'application tine d'heure
grâce à la création du profil du
célibataire le plus convoité de la
planète
des milliers de dollars sont récoltés
pour sudan politiciens stars du cinéma
et touristes du monde entier se pressent
pour rencontrer sudan
malgré cette popularité
l'avenir est sombre pour les rhinocéros
blancs du nord aucune des tentatives
d'insémination artificielle n'aboutit
les espoirs s'amenuisent au fur et à
mesure que soudaine vie
en 2018 sudan à 45 ans un âge très
avancé pour un rhinocéros
ils souffrent de dégénérescence
musculaire et osseuse et d'une infection
à la patte de jour en jour les rangers
ce le regarde s'affaiblir au point de ne
plus pouvoir se lever pour mettre un
terme à ses souffrances
la décision est alors prise de
l'euthanasier l'émotion est forte parmi
les scientifiques vétérinaire et rodgers
qui partageait son quotidien
le 19 mars 2018 sudan s'étend derrière
lui soudanais sa fille et sa petite
fille devenue les deux derniers
rhinocéros blancs du nord encore en vie
ce sont aussi deux animaux incapable de
se reproduire par ds et par maladie
confronté à l'éventualité d'une
extinction définitive l'équipe
scientifique qui s'étaient déjà
rassemblés autour de sudan décide de
tenter le tout pour le tout un projet
inédit s'élevant à plusieurs millions de
dollars et nécessitant la participation
de chercheurs sur les cinq continents
après la mort de ce jeune on se dit que
malgré tout tout espoir n'est peut-être
pas perdu comme on dispose du sperme de
sudan ait d'autres mâles rhinocéros
qu'on dispose également de vul congelés
de femelles du rhinocéros blancs du nord
on propose de faire revenir à la ville
rhinocéros blancs du nord donc l'idée
c'est de faire une fécondation in vitro
donc une fécondation en laboratoire
entre des ovules et intersport du nord
et du sperme de rhinocéros blancs du
nord
une fois la fécondation in vitro
réaliser l'idée c'est de faire une
insémination artificielle
donc il faut une femelle porteuse
malheureusement on a plus de femelle
porteuse du rhinocéros blancs du nord
les deux seules femelles encore en vie
sont plus capables de porter une
naissance interne
l'une a des faiblesses osseuse l'os
l'autre a des faiblesses au niveau de
l'utérus
donc il faut trouver une autre porteuse
par contre on a encore des rhinocéros
blancs du sud qui sont la sous-espèce
proches
donc l'idée les scientifiques c'est
d'inséminer l'embryon rhinocéros blancs
du nord dans un rhinocéros blancs du sud
en espérant que la femelle pourra mener
à terme une grossesse et faire naître un
bébé rhinocéros
ce qu'il faut voir a malgré tout c'est
qu'un projet comme celui-là mobilise
beaucoup de moyens financiers beaucoup
de moyens humains donc il ya un débat
aujourd'hui au sein du monde de la
conservation de la nature pour savoir si
on doit vraiment s'engager dans ce
projet là est-ce qu'il est bien
raisonnable d'engager autant de moyens
pour faire revenir à la vie
une espèce une sous-espèce qui vient de
disparaître alors qu'il ya quantité
d'autres espèces dans le monde qui sont
menacés notamment d'autres rhinocéros
qui sont aujourd'hui au bord de
l'extinction en août 2019
des scientifiques du laboratoire italien
avant de thé a annoncé avoir inséminer
avec succès 7e prélevés sur nagy nefa
tout aboutissant à la création de deux
embryons de rhinocéros blancs du nord
que nous communique l'histoire de sudan
c'est un engagement à l'action chaque
jour qui passe des espèces qui sera
proche de l'extinction
chaque jour qui passe les espèces qui
disparaissent aussi si on veut éviter
cela il faut agir
c'est un pari éthiques on doit faire
essayer de préserver l'intégrité de la
biodiversité
certes on a perdu la sous-espèce du
rhinocéros blancs du nord
mais on doit pas répéter l'histoire pour
d'autres espèces donc entendons cette
histoire comme un appel à agir comme une
incitation à tout de suite changer nos
comportements changer nos façons de
produire de consommer pour renouer avec
la nature pour ne plus faire contre la
nature mais avec elle et éviter à
l'avenir d'autres disparitions comme
celle du rhinocéros blancs du nord dont
faisait partie sous dun
[Musique]